burgundy is not only a fine wine but a
region in France that produces it we're
lucky to have one of the best wine
regions in the world and the wine gave
Burgundy a vast and rich culinary
tradition that continues to give our
local cuisine a good name wine is at
least partially along four Burgundy's
wealth visitors to the region would be
well advised to consult of wine guide
one who knows many of the wine growers
personally organises outings to
vineyards and takes everyone safely back
to their hotel after sampling the local
grapes the cote de nuit wine region
stretches south from Burgundy's capital
dijon towards lyon and it's home to
numerous inns offering excellent local
cuisine and Burgundy wines among them is
the Maison de Cali achieve in a
patrician house built by a prosperous
Dijon family in the late 16th century in
stark contrast to the richly decorated
facade the interior is simple and modern
in star
the young chef tour McCallum prepares a
different lunch menu for his guests
every day Dijon mustard is a staple
ingredient his forte is Burgundian
cuisine made primarily with local
produce one of his specialities is
Gaston Shepherd chicken named after a
mayor of Dijon in the 1930s he and his
wife once accepted a dinner invitation
from a famous restaurant critic but the
mayor's wife had a little mishap but it
was more boil she was fixing the chicken
the way she liked a jar of mustard fell
into the pan the taste was so strong
that it was all but inedible
so she got the idea to water it down
with some white wine and cheese and she
put it in the oven then she breaded it
and baked it with creme fraiche a
restaurant critic loved it and
christened it Gaston share our chicken
filet Gaston job so is the recipe you
cut your chicken in pieces and gradually
Brown them in a pan then place them in
the oven there will be some residue
chicken juice in the frying pan a little
mustard to this there's some grated
cheese and cream and a glass of white
wine
nozawa you etw introduced to a boil and
reduce the heat with it for it over the
chicken speckle some breadcrumbs on top
and RIS but under it's very simple to
make
don't hold on Gaston Girard chicken is a
perennial hit until Michael Long's lunch
menu eight of ten guests seen here had
ordered it it goes without saying that
it tastes best with a sauce made with
genuine Dijon mustard it can be bought
in the city's pedestrian zone where the
long-standing manufacturer my has it on
tap Dijon mustard is available in 43
flavor variations one is steeped in
shadley white wine another in cognac
another still are flavored with morals
or mango the perfect souvenir for every
visitor to Dijon